Amy has never protested before but she's
joined thousands of UK parents to
demonstrate against the crippling cost
of child care
it's become so bad for Amy and her
husband Ed that they've had to sell
their Bedford home and move closer to
her parents in leicestershire our Energy
bill has gone from 100 pounds a month to
470 pound a month
um our child care costs have gone up
seven percent in in 18 months and so
everything piling on and on and on is
you know the main driving force for us
moving to lower the mortgage to try and
make them extra pennies count
the Halloween theme is appropriate the
cost of living crisis has made it a
nightmare for families who are already
struggling to cope
[Applause]
as these demonstrations in Cardiff
and Glasgow show
parents face child care costs Rising
well ahead of inflation with the average
family paying over seven thousand pounds
per year for a part-time Nursery place
for a child under two
the equivalent full-time care costs 13
700 pounds a year that's the same as
about a third of the average monthly
income though some protesters say
they're paying about eighty percent of
their salary the organization for
economic cooperation and development
ranks the UK joints second among
developed countries for highest child
care costs that's higher than France
Sweden and Switzerland and other
European countries four thousand
nurseries went bust in the last year
because they cannot make it work under
the government subsidy anybody who's
involved in childcare knows that right
now we only subsidize children from the
age of two well what on Earth are you
supposed to do with your child until the
age of two
campaigners have three key demands
increase funding for the child care
sector properly paid maternity and
paternity leave and for all jobs to be
flexible by default the government says
it's invested over 20 billion pounds in
trying to make child care more
affordable but the families here will
tell you that's nowhere near enough but
there is one area where there might be a
concession between the government and
campaigners and that's flexible working
the government says it's Consulting on
making it a right for all employees to
request flexible working
and that will be one small step towards
helping struggling families like Amy's
oh she's Joshi Sky News in central
London